earth's oceans are home
to a symphony of aquatic life
from gargantuan whales to tiny shrimp
and coral habitats mixed in with the
calls of creatures is the music of earth
itself
from earthquakes to the patter of rain
on the surface
a new study assessed how these sonic
sources have
fared and often faltered in response to
another
more recent phenomenon
the sounds of human civilization
compared to other human threats to
marine ecosystems
such as oil spills trash and overfishing
sound pollution has taken a back seat in
regulatory debates
many scientists from oceanographers to
marine biologists to ecologists
have uncovered the dangers that human
noise poses to the world's oceans
but to date their observations haven't
led to concrete policy efforts
the new review in science dredged up
data on ocean life
and sound collected from isolated
disciplines
hoping to quantify the impacts of human
activity
on ocean soundscapes the authors divided
ocean sounds into three sources
biological geological and human
or biophony geophony and anthropone
under biophony fell an array of sounds
produced by sea animals
the crackling of crustaceans foraging
for food
the trills of seals as they breed in the
arctic during spring
the clicks and whistles of dolphins
communicating with their pod
geophony consisted of mother nature's
ceaseless songs
hurricanes deep sea faults and polar ice
cracking
at the crux of the research was
anthropone the drumbeat of
industrialized society
global shipping is a huge contributor
it's increased its low frequency ocean
noise by 32 times
offshore pile driving has a large
chronic impact
and fishing by removing animals core to
ecosystems
has quieted habitats the authors found
clear
evidence that the barrage of human-made
sound affects ocean life
438 papers showed human sounds have a
negative
impact on marine animals the evidence
was strongest for mammals
fish and invertebrates
[Music]
researchers also fear climate change has
harmful effects on ocean soundscapes
the great barrier reef has declined
significantly in recent decades
becoming far quieter coral reefs are
known to play
key roles in species settling
reproducing and hunting
animals that depend on reese's habitat
noise to breed and forage
could struggle to adapt to such drastic
change
the authors see reason for hope that
mitigation efforts can make a difference
a recent study conducted near the port
of vancouver
where shipping traffic decreased by 21
during the kovit 19 pandemic showed an
average
1.5 decibel decrease in nearby waterways
and changes to ship machinery have
proven effective
at increasing fuel efficiency while
reducing noise
the researchers are amassing a library
of ocean sounds
which they plan to analyze and diagnose
with the help of machine learning
coupling this with the reviews findings
the researchers believe they can demand
the attention of policymakers
and bring ocean's soundscapes into the
global spotlight
you